voilà bienvenus
bonjour bienvenue à sedan se termina
pour la première demi finale de ce grand
prix d'échecs que de bordeaux 2007
voilà j'ai pris avec moi avant de vous
parler de ce grand match un petit tee
shirt vous montre un petit t-shirt le
t-shirt officiel du grand prix de
bordeaux lac on a fait éditer cette
année vous voyez là donc on peut gagner
en répondant aux problèmes qui est dans
le programme du du grand prix et qui est
se trouve à l'accueil voilà donc aussi
si vous voulez vous en procurer un vous
pouvez aussi le l'acheter à l'accueil
voilà avec une photo du match et entre
laurent frayssinet est pas con valero de
l'an dernier voilà donc le petit message
publicitaire pour ce grand prix voilà je
range je range le tee shirt et
maintenant on va passer évidemment à ce
match alors pour ceux qui découvrent
qu'ils ceux qui viennent pour la
première fois aujourd'hui hier ont eu
lieu les 4 premiers quarts de finale
donc alberto david a gagné face à johan
benita ensuite laurent frayssinet a
battu le champion d'aquitaine 2006 marc
lehu mec qui a remplacé le championnat
quitte à 2007 qui pouvaient pas venir
franck hargot donc non plus et c'était
battre par laurent frayssinet ensuite
nous avons eu la grande grande surprise
d'hier c'est la victoire du jeune romain
edouard 16 ans champion d'europe cadets
et qui a battu le finaliste 2005 face à
un autre dit karpov qui a battu hicham
hamdouchi et ensuite dernier match bien
c'est mathieu cornette le maître
international bordelais qui a battu à
l'arraché aussi en blitz mort subite est
bien le grand maître international où il
vit renaît dans un match très très tendu
donc aujourd'hui dans cette première
demi finale
nous aurons donc le match entre laurent
frayssinet mathieu cornette alors avant
de présenter les joueurs de passer au
match je vais vous rappeler le principe
de ce grand prix que vous voyez ici
l'écran géant qui est connecté à
l'échiquier ici présents sur la table en
direct on va pouvoir donc suivre les
parties sur cet écran des parties de 20
minutes par joueur en match aller et
retour
donc une fois avec les blancs une fois
avec les noirs
en cas d'égalité donc ce sont des blitz
donc cinq minutes par joueur
et en cas de nouvelle égalité dans le
blitz il y aura on appelle le but mort
subite cinq minutes aux blancs 4,5 au
noir avec obligation blanc de gagner ou
perdre des matches nuls ce sont les
noirs qui l'emportent commentaires
évidemment dans les casques qui seront
données par renault lagune président de
l'échiquier bordelais et moi-même en
cabine voilà donc ça c'est pour le
spectacle voilà donc vous pouvez régler
vos cages ce que normalement vous devez
entendre ma voix ma voix dans les
casques donc première demi finale
aujourd'hui à 15 heures ici dans cet
autre femina donc le premier est bien il
est bordelais il est maître
international champion de france junior
il est autiste et là aussi été champion
de france d'ailleurs dans d'autres
catégories
c'est renaud lagune qui nous l'a précisé
hier donc idée de bordeaux c'est le
premier joueur titre est issu de
bordeaux donc pour que le jeune joueur
je sais qu'ils sont nombreux ceux qui
ont suivi ce grand prix
c'est un bel exemple à suivre il faut
évidemment l'encourager aussi fortement
champion de france junior maître
international je demande d'applaudir
bien fort le maître international
bordelais donc match cornette mathieu
cornette
bonjour mathieu alors donc content
d'être en demi finale de ce grand prix
interrogé aux échecs et de jouer leur
fait signer comme le favori de l'édition
donc bien envie de jouer donc ça va pas
être un adversaire facile évidemment
donc face à lui un peut-être le favori
de ce grand prix en tout cas un des
favoris de ce grand prix toujours en
lice donc il est grand maître
international numéro 4 français aussi
50e joueur mondial il fait partie des
meilleurs joueurs du monde il est
champion de france blitz vice-champion
d'europe de blitz deux fois vice
champion du monde chez les jeunes il a
battu deux fois l'équipe de russie avec
l'équipe de france faisant applaudir le
grand maître international laurent
frayssinet laurent frayssinet
[Applaudissements]
bonjour laurent reposer pour ce match la
forme oui c'est ce que j'ai expliqué
hier sous la forme ans et si on l'a
après le match exactement je crois que
c'est très sage de dire ça donc dû dans
l'humilité pour leur en fait signer
avant ce match alors pour arbitrer ce
match je vous avant de l'applaudir aussi
et après je vous laisse entre ses mains
pour toute la durée donc du match qui va
opposer les deux joueurs c'est le
arbitre international et patrick besse
patrick besse arbitre international ce
match elle viendra dire voilà je vous
laisse entre ses mains stéphane nous
allons donc tirer au sort les couleurs
pour la première partie de ce match
lequel de vous deux se lancent
mathieu
non
mathieu cornette a remporté le dos il va
débuter la partie avec les pièces noires
je vais vous demander de faire le plus
grand silence pendant la partie
quand vous avez le casque vous avez
tendance à parler sic au sport avec vos
voisins donc il vaut mieux ne pas en
parler pendant un parking sera discuté à
paris voilà donc si vous entendez lever
la main voilà super donc ça fonctionne
montceau parti voilà ça y est entre ce
match pour ce match première partie donc
laurent frayssinet a choisi les blancs
ou non oui donc partie du pin dames avec
défense habituelle de korn est
maintenant puisqu'il hier et nous a joué
un peu ce ce type de début donc
demi-finale très tendu entre deux
joueurs et bien du cru on va dire que
c'est vraiment le match fratricide en
admirant ces deux jours qui se
connaissent bien ils se connaissent bien
qui sont du sud ouest où les deux tous
les deux donc laurent frayssinet de dax
et donc mathieu cornette on vient de le
dire de bordeaux donc à leurs débuts on
va montrer ici donc tu pions dames c'est
cap des 4 et les noirs ont joué le coup
ici c'est 5
donc c'est comment s'appelle cette
ouverture non c'est pas en tant qu
enseigne sort du silence est une espèce
de catalan puisqu'il y avait un cavalier
f3 il va y avoir foule et de scepticisme
évidemment parce que le pion de 4 n'a
pas été joué jeudi un peu n'importe quoi
au début voilà donc ici réaction central
des nord donc évidemment on joue pour le
centre aux échecs aussi vous dis
toujours on va rappeler les fondamentaux
on peut donc ici réaction central de la
part de mathieu cornette le centre ce
sont ces quatre cases ici et 4 des 5 e 5
le 4 est important de contrôler ces
cases tout le temps au début mais aussi
au milieu de jeu et un milieu des jeux
oui donc il faut jouer pour le centre
est donc la réaction central e puissante
de mathieu corne est ici dans une
question au plan c 4 c'est à dire qu'il
peut envisager de le prendre
et lorsqu'il ne protège pas ses pions il
joue foucher 2 et il attaque mathieu
crown est maintenant le cavalier des
quatre extrêmement agressif le début de
mathieu cornette
voilà vraiment il retrouve son style
alors qu'hier il était un petit peu
contre son style dans l'est dans les
deux premières parties
en tout cas les deux parties dans 20
minutes contre olivia on est là il va
sans doute un petit peu lâché ses coups
c'est à dire prendre les risques jouer
des parties complètement ouverte avec
possibilités tactiques donc eu 82 jouer
mathieu cornette il attaque le cavalier
et ces trois là on va noter aussi que
les deux joueurs non seulement se
connaissent bien mais que mathieu
cornette a joué une partie cette année
face à laurent frayssinet à paris il a
battu et il a gagné
il a réussi à battre laurent frayssinet
donc laurent prié le vrai revanche à
prendre face à mathieu cornette et c'est
l'occasion ici à ce prix de bordeaux
dont il doit traire très très remonté
laurent frayssinet je pense ou ce match
tu comprends c'est 80 de jouer ma tuque
hornet alors à noter que les blancs pour
y récupérer ceux qui ont tout de suite
avec une manoeuvre classique damas
quatre échecs
oui et puis puis d'henri iv avec les
noirs par les emplois de répondre par
fou 17 et ensuite la dame tout
simplement prendre pioncer 4 qui peut
jouer salou rentrée ciné peut-être il va
choisir de ne pas reprendre le pion tout
de suite mais attention si les noirs
peuvent consolider ce pion et bien ça
pourrait faire un pion de plus donc il
faut alors le fameux fiant kétou à la
caisse que le fou développé sur la case
et g2 on s'y cantonner les pions sont
comme ça voilà c'est le petit le petit
flanc disaient les italiens le fia
enquête au donc de fouet placé sur le
petit flanc sur le plus petit côté
créé par l'avancée du pian g3 par
exemple se fout c'est un pour se
développer ici mais s'il y avait pas le
pion c4 ici on joue aussi b3 à b2 ça
aurait été aussi une sorte de sion qui
est tout à la fois en effet un ghetto
c'est donc une contrôle à distance du
centre et au delà du centre de la grande
diagonale jusqu'à laquelle à 8
évidemment où souvent la tour et
quelquefois un peu bloquée voilà les
cases des centrales et 15 ici en des
cinq ans no 4 est donc cette case à 8
ici où il ya la tour donc voilà il ya
beaucoup de pièces sur cette diagonale
est donc ce fou et puissant c'est un fou
très puissant voile alors le lait pour
fuir le ghetto on les utilise
essentiellement depuis les hyper moderne
depuis l'époque de réty nemirovitch est
même allée qui n'a donc dans les années
20 30 1920 1930 où ils ont proposé cette
espèce de mini révolution des échecs
avec les échecs moderne hypermoderne on
appelait ça les hyper moderne dans les
appeler petit rouquin jouer laurent ce
cinéma-là la sécurité des rois qu'on met
le roi deux cases à droite et la tour
passe par dessus ici sur la case f1
voilà on centralise donc plus tard cette
tour pour revenir au centre il le roi
est bien à l'abri derrière samouraï de
pions voile alors donc laurent n'a pas
récupéré le pion à 4 mai il avait
installé le cavaliere des 4 mathieu
cornette a sorti le fouet avec tempo un
jour poussé 5 qui attaquent quelques
attaques et le cavalier avec dame plus
fous il est cavalier n'étaient pas des
bien sûr cavaliers b5 pour se soustraire
à la tacc alors le coup trois qui
auraient défendu le cavalier thème coup
critiquable pour plusieurs raisons parce
que ils affaiblissent et les cases
blanches en particulier la case f3 et il
gênait la sortie du phocéen lacoste et 3
est évidemment bien sur la case d3 qui
était accessible et il empêcher le fou
de sortir un cavalier ça faisait
beaucoup d'inconvénients
donc ils veulent voilà ce coût est
intéressant à noter parce que si les
noirs évidemment prennent admission
après la reprise par la tour les noirs
peuvent pas se permettre de faire
n'importe quoi puisque la menace serait
alors caressé 7 avec la fameuse
cet échec au roi et menacent de prendre
la tour donc le cavalier ici menace un
petit peu la casse c'est 7 ce qui limite
les possibilités des noirs oui et le
blanc menace aussi les jouets dame prend
un des huit pour des rockets les blancs
menace d'un probable
le roi mort mais les noirs encore un
petit peu plus même s'il obtient 6,4
semble un peu faible pour l'instant
voilà donc il faudra un moment donné se
préoccuper quand même v6 avec attaques
des cavaliers b5 et prescient sur la
case f2 alors effectivement la menace
des morceaux de prendre le cavalier
dessin est effectivement comme renault
vient de le signaler
eh bien il ya une pression ici quand
même sur cette diagonale même si le pion
est pour l'instant de protéger par la
tournée on voit que lecavalier pourrait
bondir sur g4 pour attaquer encore un
peu plus ce pion f2 ou que les noirs peu
pourrait jouer aussi le coup et trois
wild 4-3 attaquant les cases noires mais
mais ça libérerait la puissance du fou
j'ai deux sas et voilà peut être un
souci
donc il faut aussi chez les noirs 100 g
a terminé le développement à trouver de
la sécurité pour le roi qui est encore
au centre parce qu'attention pour
l'instant c'est l'âge et des actions
voient l'arrêt serait peut-être temps je
sers pas tous d'attaqué avec deux pièces
il vaut mieux faire mobiliser ses forces
avant de se lancer à l'attaqué des
troupes d'où le petit rond petit rock
sécurité du roi logique on termine le
développement par le petit os ou leroy
l'abri on voit bien que la tour
maintenant on va pouvoir éventuellement
se centralise et si besoin
très vite d'où l'intérêt du rock
évidemment l'atout rit beaucoup plus
active ici où elle peut venir au centre
protéger le pion ici attaqué la dame
alors que tout à l'heure elle était en
cours sur la case à schwyz où le faisais
rien vous l'intérêt du rock qu'on aurait
petra jamais assez vite
voilà et puis la base la base de la
conduite la partie d'échec c'est la
sécurité du roi fou et 4 très
intéressant la parlement fascinant
maintenant que le fou et un f4 on pourra
peut-être plus tard joué le coup et
trois ça sera moins grave même si on n'a
pas envie de jouer ce coup parce qu'on
veut pas affaiblir cette quasi si
détroit qui quand même contrôlé par deux
pions imaginons que les blancs jouent
ici
beaucoup comme eux trois et bien une
manoeuvre comme qu'avait laissé six
cavale et b4 à menaçant de s'installer
avec un gros cavaliers en d3 quasiment
imprenable
donc attention à ne pas affaiblir comme
ça ses pions en à noter que donc ce
qu'ils on contrôle la caisse des trois
voiles alors cavaliers à 6 pour parer la
menace directe et qui était cavalier
c'est certain joue un fouet f4 leblanc
menacé cavaliers csn va l'initier à tête
la tour qui était enfermé à l'adar
l'angle alors que là c'est plus possible
puisque le cavalier à 6 contrôler la
casse et 7 et donc c'est assez simple à
comprendre tous ses coups heureusement
qu'on arrive à comprendre un peu quand
même rêver et ces chèques sont faits
d'éléments simples qu'il faut mettre
boutabout voilà ce qui est plus dur
c'est d'arriver
les coureurs arrivent à les comprendre
par contre pourquoi les coups
s'enchaînent
oui oui mais très souvent quand on
regarde les très fort joueur
ils ont un jeu assez limpide et lisible
et est simple mais ses coups simples
sans justement difficile à réaliser pour
un amateur
parce qu'il faut avoir mûri beaucoup de
choses pour arriver à faire un simple
alors au niveau du tournoi à noter que
laurent frayssinet a gagné très
facilement hier 2-0 mais que ma tuque
hornet est revenu quasiment de l'enfer
puisque il était un peu dire perdant
archi perdant est virtuellement éliminée
voilà face à olivier rhône et mais il a
réussi à trouver une ressource
complètement c'est la force des débords
joueurs andy club un joueur est toujours
chanceux ce qui est vrai il était en
difficulté ils allaient simplement perd
la partie mais mais la chance a été avec
lui
il a provoqué aussi c'est pas faux les
mêmes quand il était très mal est foutu
il a suivi le précepte de karpov qui
disait dans un de ces boues cannes quand
j'ai une position difficile ou inférieur
eh bien je joue le coup qui ne perd pas
tout de suite
c'est à dire qu'il me laisse en vie et
qui me laisse encore des quelques
possibilités l'adversaire peut se
tromper adversaire n'est pas le monstre
froid
cybernétix est un humain donc le
l'humain peut se tromper je suis à
l'erreur adverse alors on va expliquer
le dernier coup de laurent frayssinet
d'un coup simple on a on défend pardon
le câble et b5 on peut menacer
éventuellement à 5 pour chasser la dame
de b6 de cette case
il ya quand même cette pression un peu
désagréable ici sur f2 sur ce pion ici
du roi donc on pourrait jouer à 5 et la
dame sur l'obligé de partir allégeant la
préparation et deuxième idée le pion
protège le cavaly b5 donc la menace des
blancs immédiate ces cavaliers pros eux
quatre d'où le voilà ça explique le coup
suivant de le coup dams et 6 pour la
fois il évite à 5 et en même temps ils
protègent le pion aux quatre sites et
maintenant attaquées par le cavalier est
dans le coup alors l'autre idée du coût
du kw à 4 bien évidemment c'est de
freiner la majorité noire c'est à dire
que pour que la majorité se réalise il
faudra
jouez prudemment les pions beldame les
pieux le pion à cet été et bessette pour
un jour espérer avoir un pur passée donc
il faudra d'abord joué b6 puis à 6 puis
b 5 c'est à dire ça prendra beaucoup de
temps et non pas dans l'ordre inverse
puisque s'ils ont joué à six en premier
le pion à avance rien à 5 et cambrai en
passant et en blocs réel et la mobilité
de 7,2 cette majorité donc c'est un coup
à la fois utiles dans le moment est
utile pour pour l'avenir de la finale
alors pour l'instant le souci quand même
des noirs c'est que cette dame ne
montrait bien le protège le 4 mai elle
est toujours en vis-à-vis du fou j'ai
deux quand même qu'ils ramassent ici la
dame est potentiellement la torah 8
même si encore le cube et 7 mai donc ça
il mobilise un peu les noirs tout ça
alors le problème du matériel gagner ce
qui est le cas ici lampions de plus et
quand on veut s'accrocher absolument à
ce plan de plus souvent on place ses
pièces une manière un peu un coordonnées
et le joueur qui a le matériel a moins
le piano - lui ont regagné ses pièces et
va tirer profit donc méfiez vous du gain
de matériel quand quand on peut pas
organiser ses pièces une fois le
matériel gagner ou g5 attaque le
cavalier psy ce qui est le défenseur de
4,1 tout ça c'est logique
le défenseur de ce pion de ce pion voilà
l'idée c'est de prendre évidemment le
cavalier et ensuite de gober le pion
central
voilà c'est toujours la lutte pour pour
le centre et pour des temps les détruire
ce centre que les clés noires possède et
lançant une supériorité au sort pour les
camions qui occupe une des cases et mes
quatre cas centrales amorties mes
galères en supporter un peu fragile
alors le pion de plus des noirs c'est
celui ci voyez pour l'instant ce plan
n'est nenê palier il n'a pas le
défenseur de pierre naturelle
donc il est un peu en train de planer
et c'est à dire qui peut se faire
ramasser à tout moment il est il est en
l'air la fameuse pièce aux pieds en
l'air sarr qui n'est pas défendu
il n'est pas défendu alors notez que
même si une pièce pouvait prendre ce
pion ce serait une erreur imaginons on
va regarder juste rapidement dame b 1
dames à 2 et si on prenait le pion c4 ce
serait une erreur pourquoi parce qu'il
ya eu le coup il faut prendre deux
échecs au roi on reprend le fond et on
voit bien que la dame sait si ça prête
pour reprendre la dame en c4 on est très
loin de ça mais tout simplement à
signaler qu'il est n direct voilà le
client est elle directement défendu
alors faut il faisait bien joué de la
part mathieu cornette qui s'est dit bon
me matin comme défenseur du pion aux 4
et bien c'est pas grave je vais défendre
ce pion avec une autre pièce et la
hockeyeuse y est un joyau naturel le
développement en développement je
développe mon fond non mais c'est ok je
vais pouvoir libérer matour et 8 qui va
pouvoir venir au centre par exemple ont
des huit pour attaquer la dame blanche
pourquoi pas tout à fait envisageable et
là laurent frayssinet de réfléchir sans
doute beaucoup qui me semblent candidats
le coup-franc cavaliers puisque sur dame
rend fou en récupère le pied avec quatre
interruptions au iv par exemple par cas
va les prendre quatre oui il faut
prendre un coup franc et un cas où j'ai
d'autres permis de récupérer pardon le
coup mais la dame à m6 pourrait prendre
b2 et adam a pris au final effectivement
pourrait prendre permet de donc ça plus
compliqué donc il faut calculer tout ça
on va pas rentrer là dedans parce que ça
c'est la limite c'est le oui mais les
remettre au boulot le joueur de voir
l'échiquier est obligé de calculer ça et
le calcul et le plus loin possible c'est
à dire après que va-t-il se passer car
j'aurais joué dame prend b2 que va jouer
le bla en ce moment là est ce qu'il y a
un coût intéressant auparavant la
variante 30 cavaliers oui dans prend car
l'épreuve 14.4 fou prend l'égalité et à
la fin boudin prend b2 mais là le ceto
blanc de jouer peut-être le blanc peut
jouer un coup un coup comme je ne sais
pas moi
d'am dam des cinq qui attaquent le pian
c4 comme des mécènes qui attaqua la
phobie sais pas qui attaquent décède c4
alors à ce moment là elle est ce que le
noir je veux faire quelque chose et
c'est donc c'est la profondeur de calcul
est ce que il n'ya pas de salle ont
fasciné les revenus en d4 ici et à oui
très jolie de l'appartement fasciné
puisque c'est une fourchette ici entre
la dame et le four donc qui force presse
les noirs à donner leurs voix là il
vient de s'en doute de gagner la paire
de faux très simple en fait
il vient de gagner la paire de fois un
coup la tuerie a observé que les deux
pièces dame sait si c'est fou et cinq
étaient à distance de cavaliers cela
casse des quatre donc fourche est
naturel de cavaliers fonction naturelle
et c'est vrai que ce fou il était quand
même fort fou un puissant bien sûr
qu'ils attaquent et quand même sur les
quinze mois bien sûr on est bien content
de pouvoir l'éliminer
alors que les le faut qu'il faut donner
à ce qu'il faut donner le fou de cases
blanches ou le fou de cases noires alors
la vie sur les noirs peuvent choisir
encore de jouer un coup comme par
exemple dame
[Musique]
17h27 dame vers nos écrans voilà il
donne le full cases noires c'est sa
décision évident de savoir où mettre la
dame parce qu'il fallait continuer à
défendre souffou oui donc après dame
prend maintenant le fou blanger devient
fou actifs et puissant qui tape sur un
pion ennemis et il a la paire de fous
ils allaient de fou qui peuvent
justement après faut pré m6 désarticulé
la défense des pions du plus petit rock
noise exactement très certainement les
noirs vont chasser cette dame par le
coup tour des huit par exemple pour
chasser cette dame qui fait pression sur
sur le cavalier 6 avec le fou voyez ils
peuvent ils peuvent avoir un homme et
non pas pour à des huit puisque ça se
heurterait peut-être assauts simple dame
prend à cette wii et l'entourent huit
tours évite donc on protège l'aï
surprotège se plie en 4 parce qu'il sait
que si le père le fou va devenir
redoutable le fou g2 donc ce pion
quelque part jane allez les blancs dans
leur expansion
il faut qu'ils gardent ce pion en a
quatre vivent le plus longtemps possible
cette notion de double fou ici donc il
est prêt à redon il est prêt à se
laisser prendre en abscisse 1 puisque
cavaliers si oui il faut prendre
ce qui détruirait un peu les plus
endurants noir il va falloir reprendre
du pillon oui devant vous avec la dame
d'abord on jouera d'abord dame prend
mais il y aura ainsi on prendre la dame
ya peut-être dame prend 6,4 et récupère
son pion sinon prend 9 6 et en détruit
des les pions nous armer mais on
maintient bien fortement ce pion à 4 qui
gêne quelque part les la coordination
des pièces blanc à nice le champion 4
est la clé de la position parce que
voilà donc a non seulement un tome qui
ont assez fort pour le noir parce qu'il
est au centre mais il bouche aussi la
puissance du coup j'ai 2 alors pour
l'instant ce fou tape dessus et c'est
peut-être peut-être il espère un jour
exploiter sa majorité de pions donc
aller sur la meme si c c c de même si
c'est la honte parce que notre ami
freyssinet a pris des précautions mais
le coup à 4 pour pour freiner justement
cette majorité alors à noter ses pions
ici effectivement majorité utilisent et
renault -3 3 contre 2 contre 2
très bien donc la tour d un logis que
devant facile et voilà on ramène une
tour en jeu on contrôle bien ici on voit
bien la colonne des ce qu'on appelle la
colonne d ici la colonne avec deux
pièces lourdes
voilà tranquillement voilà c'est le
principe de la colonne aux verts font
pas pression il y apprend des champions
il estime que sa pression centrale sur
e4 wire le cavaly étapes sur quatre le
foot absurde 4 la dame aussi la pression
aussi sur le cavaliere 6 qui défend le 4
ici et maintenant on rajoute un peu de
pression en mettant une tour au centre
voilà et puis quand on regarde
l'échiquier on voit qu'une seule colonne
entièrement ouverte c'est la colonne des
essais très importante de masse et les
pièces lourdes sur la colonnade et c'est
à dire de dominer la colonne verte la
couleur verte apporte hier à celui qui
peut doubler dans cette colonne
et même triplé et bien sûr pour pouvoir
ensuite utiliser cette colonne comme à
voie de pénétration dans le camp ennemi
c'est le principe d' école ouverte voici
les sentiers à la tête et il a il a un
petit peu de retard au temps papa pas
énorme mais il est un petit peu
autant alors très important on va parler
du temps effectivement neuf minutes 50
contre 10 min bon ça y est ça y est
cornet était en train de revenir à
égalité autant qualité autant donc il
faudra quand même qui récupère son pied
un jour sinon ce pion va peser au moment
de la finale et une partie au chaos donc
ces 20 minutes par joueur et si on
arrive à zéro seconde renault voilà
cavaliers oui oui si on arrive à 0
secondes oui à bien des deux joueurs a
perdu le premier qui est arrivé à zéro
c'est çà premier qui arrive à zéro
voilà c'est important de gérer son temps
c'est très important si on a plus dans
mon père on a vu des partis hier se
terminer comme ça et oui tout à fait et
romain edouard d'ailleurs habituellement
de douchy oui autant autant en le
faisant tomber ce qu'on arrête ton bep
ton cap alliés b 4-1 alors c'était la
pièce la plus passive des noirs 1 avec
la torah vite donc il améliore cette
pièce alors il donne la priorité à aux
cavaliers et puisqu'un cavaliers met du
temps à se déplacer sur l'échiquier
c'est une beta les petites pattes
d'araignée qui met du temps pour
atteindre 1,15 lointaine de l'échiquier
alors que la tour 1 de coûts voilà et
c'est important sur l'échiquier donc
distingue fric avec le câble est une
pièce à courte portée
effectivement donc il va il peut pas
aller plus loin qu'ici peut pas les
contrôles et des cases là bas alors que
le fou lui est une pièce à l'ombre
portée un fou par exemple henri iv
contrôler jusqu en v8
voilà donc on le fout et à longue portée
mais par contre il ne contrôle que les
cases noires alors que le cavalier lui
peut contrôler alternativement des cases
blanches et quand il est sur une case
blanche y contrôler ensuite des cases
noires donc qui peut choisir les cases
qu'ils contrôlent donc voilà il ya des
avantages des inconvénients mais dans
ces deux pièces mais à petits pas le
cavalier un petit pas donc là le
cavalier à 6
cavalier à la bande voyez il est
toujours très intéressant sur
l'échiquier d'essayer de trouver les
meilleurs 15 les meilleures classes pour
les pour les cavaliers faut prendre f6
parce que peut-être lorsqu'il joue adam
prendre ces quatre sissili adam prend m6
eh bien il gagna un tempo sur le
cavalier qui aiment jouer mais quatre
imaginons pour le nord le coup logique
ce serait de faire d'un point m6 pour
dire bon si tu veux me casser ma
structure de pions de les droits c'est
possible mais d'abord tu devras avait
changé les dames et je resterai quand
même avec un terme plus mais dans ce cas
là sont un problème si ce qu'il ferait
dans prend on sait qu'avec des mots sur
le cavalier qui vient de s'installer
l'arrêt attaqué qui profitent de ce
petit passage du cavalier qui voulait
sans doute revenir en d5
oui ou remplacer la dame 1 c6 revenir
ans et six à pouvoir un jour à l'air 9,5
et viser la case d3 que lorsque le coup
et 3 aura été joué et on va vous
rembourser 6 éventuellement pour passer
en 5 et contrôler ses cases ici mais qui
pour l'instant sont bien tenus en
respect par ce point tant que ceux qui
embauchent pas il faut pas bouger
c'est là qu'on voit que c'est vrai qu'il
faut bien réfléchir avant de bouger les
pires oui bien sûr qu'à ce faible après
c
campion abandonne la case d3 imaginez ce
que de trois places et une grosse faute
de la part des noirs des blancs pardon
puisque les noires mettraient un
carrière qui serait très puissant
imprenable est très puissant et très
puissant il boucherie l'avenir de la
tour ils contrôleraient des cases très
grave dans le camp blanc dont qui serait
un espèce de gros poissons
les blancs sont quasiment étouffé mais
tant que ce pion gars c'est pas possible
puisque tout simplement prendre et
cavaliers voilà on donnerait une pièce
qui conduirait dans matthieu réfléchi à
ce qu'il tout de suite d'emilie de sa
structure avec g prend 1,6 ou est-ce
qu'il prend de la dame pour conserver la
structure intacte et à ce moment-là il
rend le pion c4 alors pour garder son
pion il faut qu'ils jouent g prend m6 il
veut garder le pian ces quatre là comme
ça ils gardent adav à la protection du
thon ces quatre noms ils préférent qui
préfère rendre le pion il prend pas le
pion bah oui bien sûr il ne prend pas
parce que parce qu' eelv a dominé la
colonne la colonnade et il va rentrer
sur la colonne des puisqu'il a le tempo
sur le pion ces quatre là tacle il va
donc que menacer tour fdr donc c'est
énorme parce que si l'on arrive à
récupérer le pion ce plan de plus que
pour il aura et la structure en plus et
il aura le pion il aurait égalisé le
matériel et il aura une meilleure
structure oui parce que cette structure
là surtout est très faible
effectivement il aura cassé le la
structure du roi noir
une telle structure de pions permet pas
aux joueurs de jouer facilement
exception puisque on voit bien qu'ils
sont bloqués le purifient 7 et le pion
et 6 sont ce qu'on appelle ici ses deux
pions des pions doublé et on voit bien
que le pion à vii par exemple ne peut
pas ans est un peu plus ici c'est devant
lui débloquer voile ailleurs des pions
croyez-vous de mal à être mobiles oui on
voit aussi la force du coup à 4 qui ne
permet pas aux copiant b52 défendent
natural avant son collègue c4 et le land
le plus cool le coutour c8 qui est le
col tour à ses 8 qui me coûte défenses
naturelles bien il ya cavaliers b5 et
menace une fourchette en d6 tu vas trop
vitraux de voir qui est qui peut être
terrible avoir montré les doyens donc tu
voulais dire la tour
qui viendra assez vite que le coût
naturel mais il y aurait entre autres
cavaliers b5 pour défendre
oui ce pion voilà y aurait cavaliers
bessin qui attaquent au passage le pion
à sète et qui menace et qui menacent
cavaliers des six pour ce temps les
pièces et en particulier le fief 5 à une
triplette en triangle est haut de
fourchette un trident trident trois
pieds sont prises mais bon on en est pas
encore là
mathieu ben hassen doute rendre le pion
pour contester la colonnade et je pense
qu'il va jouer tu auras des vite pour
contester la colonne d epuis ans dans le
pion et surtout repenser ses 4 il jouera
cavaliers c6 pour recycler son cavalier
mais restera avec sa structure affaibli
aller loin et puis dans ce cas la
structure affaiblissement fausse idée
mais bon le le coutour des cas très très
fort parce que il ajoute une attaque de
quatre qui se trouve attaqué trois fois
par le cahier c3 le fou g2 et la tour
des quatre donc on menace de non
seulement de récupérer un pion mais
peut-être d'en gagner un donc profond
sur la stratégie lourd en russie des
renault c'est donc une stratégie qui
consiste à ne pas reprendre directement
le pion mais d'abord à affaiblir
l'adversaire et reprendre plus tard avec
voilà ça c'est ça parce que l'adversaire
c'est un peu un coordonnées pour pour un
tenir artificiellement son pion alors la
torah des 8
c'est le coût que je conseillais donc
trois des huit pour contester tout de
suite la colonne et pour pouvoir en cas
de toux reprend ses quatre rentrèrent
des deux tours tours d2 pas tout de
suite évidemment pas ce qu'est le
cavalier ya le cavalier en l'air mais
jouer je veux jouer le cavalier puis
puis essayer de rentrer sur sa lancée
non non parce que lecavalier b4 et en
l'air à lecavalier se remplit oui donc
qu'il faut voilà ce que l'on remplit
voilà laurent fait signer préfère
d'abord tenir la colonne voilà laurent
frayssinet préfère avant d'aborder la
colonne les eaux les menaces restent
identiques
non je réfléchissais à cavaler ces six
attaquants la tour mais alors pour quand
même prendre l'option ses quatrièmes en
cas de prise en d1 on peut encore
reprendre du cavalier tout à fait
pourtant tout à fait important donc
c'est laisser la force et la différence
à prendre en main très remettre c'est
que le grand maître lui n'a pas peur de
laisser provisoirement de matériel c'est
ça qui est difficile analyse au d'échec
les compensations qu'on a pour le
matériel donné même minime comme un
petit pion qu'on récupérera plus tard
parce qu'on aura une meilleure
coordination des pièces là c'est une
belle et une modération de ce thème là
il le fait et fait ce que je propose oui
ou la nouvelle et son site internet où
il fallait le jouer et il n'a pas peur
de tout reprendre tour wintour prend
puisque après tout reprendre cavalli
prend il en reste avec tout au plus oui
mais il récupère et le pian 4 puisque le
pion à 4 cela est attaqué il peut le
faire mais ils vérité moi la boue il a
toujours sa majorité puis laura soulager
les pièces lourdes et donc la position
sera tenable
c'était jouable trois pions contrôle de
ce côté ne pas oublier effectivement la
majorité l'éloigner lorsque en gazole
elle dame même finale de roissy pour une
position avantageuse pour les noirs
voyez le pion à éloigner ce qu'on
appelle le qui ont passé éloigné savoir
les noirs peuvent se créer ce qu'on
appelle un pion pas c'est donc un pion
qui n'aura pas depuis en face de lui
vont simplement bouger les pions
échanger ses deux pions contre deux
pions noirs il restera un pion qui
obligera le roi aller le chercher
voilà et en attendant le renoir prendra
les pions de l'autre côté donc c'est des
stratégies gagnantes à long terme à très
long terme
mais les joueurs connaissent très bien
tout ça donc il est possible que laurent
frayssinet ne rentre pas dans cette
variante avec échange de tours détours
prend des 80 on évite tout reprendre si
si si quand même
il a dû estimer que oui bah il veut
récupérer son pion et détenir sa finale
que sont ces pays là il a aussi la
majorité sur les droits il il restera
avec quatre contre trois sur les droits
lui aussi il pouvait jouer tout reprend
pas trop penser car oui pour y jouer ton
prince et kate
oui parce qu'il estime que sa majorité
et plus elle n'a pas non plus
oui il veut garder une tour il n'a pas
non plus échangées les tours il veut
garder une tour précédent le cerveau et
échanger la deuxième tour et après
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fait il comprend
quatre caves l'épreuve quatre peut-être
on est sûr de miser sur la faiblesse du
plan s'est calqué sur qui et sur blanc
en s'aidant de l'attaqué peut-être avec
le fou mais enfin on n'en est pas là
puisque finalement c'est parce qu'il
était joué dans tron prend pour cavaler
prend voilà donc on est dans une second
appel une finale renault louis une
finale puisque les dames ne sont plus là
ça devient une finale quelque chose
d'assez les techniques tour des cadences
à l option c4 et perdu pourquoi le seul
coup qui permettrait le défendre c'est
fou 6 mais dans ce cas là c'est durant 4
qui tombe
voilà d'ailleurs peut-être que les
blancs vont peut-être même pas prendre
le pion sait qu'à tout de suite mais
d'abord les clients 4 et noir risque de
perdre deux pions la wii comme quoi
offrir leur offre ici ne s'est pas
pressée du tout du petit peu près serré
en option il a au contraire activer ces
pièces donc on voit l'intérêt de
l'activité on voit bien que l'activité
est souvent supérieure au matériel et si
on génère une très bonne activité on
peut prendre le temps
le bon moment attendre le bon moment
pour reprendre le matériel et on s'en
sortir avec un avantage
ouais positionnelle voire même des fois
même matériel on peut aussi réussir plus
que ce qu'on a investi un peu c'est un
peu ça et bizarrement plus les joueurs
sont forts plus ils sont habiles avec
très peu de pièces
on pourrait penser qu avec très peu de
pièces le joueur plus faible va pouvoir
se débrouiller placer ses pièces b non
encore pour coordonner très peu de
pièces là c'était l'idée de lâcher il a
c'était l'idée de mathieu c'était de
récupérer la colonne des pour avoir le
contre jeu sur le pion b2 il veut jouer
pour attaquer un peu le pion aux 2 qui
pour test et le pian médoc et le pian b
de la tour en deuxième comme on appelle
ça donc il veut donc là probablement que
les blancs il s'est dit quelque chose
pour recevoir autre chose ils cèdent pas
gratuitement
voilà les blancs ont été replacés plus
nos travailleurs de prendre avec le fond
voilà c'est ce qu'il a fait oui franc
avec le fou pour avoir le tempo sur m6
voilà faut prendre quatre et voilà
maintenant il peut prendre du cavalier
avec l'idée du tempo ce qu'on appelle le
tempo c'est simplement en prenant il
apte à quelques
avec la pièce en bougeant attaque en
plus avec les autres choses
sa double tempo il peut reprendre
cavalier peut aussi choisir de reprendre
le travail et l'intérêt aussi dur plus
du cas il y aura des ses prières les
contrôles des deux mois du fcf c'est
bien sûr pour chasser le cavalier de d2
mais encore le cavalier s attaquent à
cette option
attac baisse est alors les noirs ont
probablement ici le pas trop le choix
puisque sur b6 le simple cavaliers
detroit bush
la colonne de la tour donc peut-être que
les noirs ont intérêt à jouer depuis
tours d2 mais doit réfléchir à ça c'est
pas évident c'est pascal a cavalé
prendre 17 avec tempo encore puisque en
attaque le cavalier c'est si les séries
ceci sera attaqué mais on pourrait faire
un contre au tempo et renault avec tours
prend b2 oui
iata plus riches et on s'orienterait
vers une finale deux tours plutôt égal à
mes avantages blanc on l'aimé peu
sensible puisque puis ont un seul pion
sur l'ale dames et puis trois pions
contre 4 sur l'ensemble elle sur
l'aileron donc il va jouer il va jouer
sa c6 30 17
il veut jouer la finale deux tours si
possible quand même groupe sans plus
mais bon sur une même l 4 contre 3 ou 3
contre 2 c'est si difficile à
concrétiser oui dans une finale de
tournoi il le fait parce que c'est quand
même sa meilleure chance
petit coup intermédiaire alors mathieu
mathieu aime bien des coûts
intermédiaires comme ça très souvent
mais et glisse un petit coup
intermédiaire dans une variante qui a
l'air force et hop il oublie pas le
problème des armes et des contrôles des
fois aussi il a des petites idées oui ah
oui mais laurent fournier se laisse pas
impressionner b4 les cas qui laisse
tomber le pion aux deux et il se dit
j'ai deux pions contraire voilà c'est
maintenant moi qui ai la fameuse royer
vérité oui mais surtout parce que ce
cavalier n'a pas tellement de cases de
repli le cavalier noir ça va être
tellement il est innée prix oui il faut
qu'il aille en déca prévoit louis puis
en os 6 pour trouver les cases et par
l'installation aux rites et avant ce
plan là mathieu cornette c'est pas
facile c'était pas facile à jouer
oui c'était facile à laquelle des quatre
a été forcée quasiment voilà ce que le
rend facile il va jouer comme des cinq
possibles on peut toujours à continuer à
avancer les pions
oui oui bien sûr la bulle est purement
ce pluie menace de faire dame plus ça va
obliger les noirs entendent occuper
et si les noirs ça n'occupe trop de ce
côté aussi de l'échiquier on va pouvoir
aller manger ses pions faible en les
attendant petit détail l'alcool petit
détail le clouage il a bien réalisé ça
au détail
oui le clouage le cavaly ci bouge eh
bien c'est la tour qui saute alors la
finale de cavalli skyrock ça y est il
est blanc il va essayer de rentrer dans
la finale de cavaliers menace cavaliers
sait si ce sur quoi il y aura cavaliers
b3 forcer les tons son tour cavaliers
prendrait la majorité la majorité et
s'échappe et le pion à septembre et la
majorité assez forte mais le coup aussi
se heurtent peut-être à tour des six
échecs joue cavalier b3 avant alors là
c'est joli coup techno avantage pendant
3 minutes 40 contre 2 minutes de jeu la
tactique le aussi le temps pourquoi il
est bien sûr nos trois minutes de la fin
gros avantage blanc wheeler le signaler
puisque maintenant comme ces évidences
mais il faut que le voilà il veut il va
chercher plus rang 6 à 7
et les noirs n'ont pas de solution pour
le défendre à 600 écoles ratsiraka 08
il faudrait qu'on peut attaquer sur un
pion ça va être difficile donc il va
jouer à 6 puis à 5
il va jouer je pense que la loi 5 voilà
donc sur bessin qui va essayer de jouer
que les c4 pour contrôler l'avancée du
saillant c'est foutu et c'est foutu le
pion étant l'ennemi du cavalier deux
pions à deux ennemis donc ça veut dire
qu'on va falloir été il va falloir
donner le 100 m dames
la poussée oui mais je voulais à 5 mais
oui même jouer il faut jouer à saint
tout de suite je pense là à 5 tout de
suite les intéresserait jolifou bien sûr
voilà il loge unie et il le joue essayé
depuis empêchés à 7 et 8 ans willet les
pions à un ennemi du cavalier ont encore
frappé
bravo regardez ce qui peut rester
cavaliers pros et mieux ça c'est
évidemment un peu plus lent est venu
quelle belle partie de le battre est
super party l'air de laurent frayssinet
qui a donné un pion apparemment en
voyons pas quelles étaient les
compensations mais c'était simplement
pour que les pièces sont parfois mal
placé et que lui en sortent avec des
pièces bien placé pour récupérer son
empire au moment où l'on m'a fait rire
est encore vive 16 des boulets qu'elle
[Musique]